[Música]
como ya lo adelantamos continuamos con
daniela blandón que el día de ayer
estuvo haciendo todo el cubrimiento
especial de las elecciones en colombia
para nuestro oficial de noticias aquí en
france 24
danny pues quien mejor que usted para
hablar entonces de lo que ocurrió ayer
era algo muy importante digamos la
derrota a los partidos tradicionales y
la victoria para las encuestadoras no
claro y lo decía gustavo petro en su
discurso él decía el presidente eduque y
sus partidos aliados han perdido su
proyecto de gobierno su proyecto ha sido
derrotado que esta es una derrota para
el centro democrático realmente porque
pues ha venido digamos en los últimos 20
años dirigiendo toda la política en
colombia con excepción del 2014 cuando
fue elegido el ex presidente de juan
manuel santos que en ese momento era
opositor de álvaro uribe del resto todo
el tiempo ha sido
casi que una hegemonía política de
álvaro uribe y sus centro democrático
ahora hay otro punto para analizar raúl
y es que los uribistas se quedaron sin
candidatos desde tenían una opción a que
era óscar iván zuluaga el exministro de
hacienda después tuvieron una opción ve
cuando óscar iván se retira un día
después de los comicios del 13 de marzo
que era federico gutiérrez y ahora
tienen que optar por una opción sé que
ni siquiera les gusta entonces todos los
partidos tradicionales ahora van a tener
que sumarse a esta campaña o no a
sumarse pero sin sumar sus votos a esta
campaña de rodolfo hernández ahora se
mencionaba las encuestadoras ellas
siempre dieron por favorito a gustavo
petro y de 2º federico gutiérrez y así
se mantuvo a lo largo de toda la campaña
pero en las últimas semanas si bien
rodolfo hernández no escalaba el segundo
lugar propiamente porque quedaron en
empate técnico si fue reduciendo esa
brecha y en las últimas yo diría que en
las últimas dos semanas fue cuando luego
se afianzó y acá así es danny y pues una
remontada bastante grande no no fue
solamente por unos pocos votos si no fue
por por cientos de miles de votos no lo
que tuvo de un millón de votos y es
danny y la victoria también para la
participación ciudadana en colombia no
hay que olvidar eso no hay que olvidarlo
raúl porque mide 21 millones de personas
salieron a las urnas venciendo también
este tema de la abstención que ha sido
históricamente alta en colombia esta es
la más alta de este siglo la
participación y la abstención a su vez
es inversamente proporcional al 45 por
ciento la más baja en los últimos años
en la historia reciente del país casi 2
millones de personas más que en 2018
salieron a votar este domingo en
colombia
bueno danny y menos mal que usted está
aquí en el estudio y sé que todo lo sabe
que todo lo ve lv con una pregunta del
millón a ver si la pega dios mío y si lo
hace pues allá va a ser mi pitonisa
personaje está a donde se van los apoyos
de los derrotados en estas elecciones
bueno yo voy a comenzar con una paradoja
y es que el establecimiento el que
llamamos el establecimiento a los
partidos tradicionales va a tener que
votar obligadamente por algún candidato
anti establecimiento eso ya es un punto
bastante relevante para tener en cuenta
hagamos las cuentas porque yo no soy
pitonisa pero sí
petro tiene 85 millones de votos rodolfo
hernández tiene 6 millones de votos y la
lucha hasta entonces entre esos 5
millones de votos de federico gutiérrez
él ya ha dicho que los va a sumar así
que si sumamos los de rodolfo hernández
y los de federico gutiérrez tendríamos
11,5 millones de votos que es lo que
necesitaría el aspirante en segunda
vuelta para llegar al palacio de nariño
veremos entonces también hacia dónde se
van esos 888.000 votos de sergio fajardo
el candidato de centro que todavía no ha
dicho a quién va a apoyar entonces la
clave podría estar ahí y podría estar
también entre los entre las personas que
seguían a fico y que eventualmente no
quieran que llegue a la presidencia este
señor rus está gobernando fernández así
es danny pues igual todo está sobre la
mesa vamos a ver qué va a pasar en estas
ediciones tan impredecibles como las que
vimos el día de ayer pues la sorpresa
que yo robo el finlandés no claro que sí
y es que en la sorpresa que dio rodolfo
hernández la sorpresa que dieron las
personas que salieron a votar
efectivamente ahora lo que tenemos que
hacer es mirar son 10 5 millones de
votos todos a sacar calculadoras en sus
discursos sus discursos fueron bastante
emotivos yo personalmente que estuve en
la campaña de federico gutiérrez pues vi
muchas caras largas por supuesto claro
pues también lo estaban ovacionando y
diciéndoles sí cuenten con nuestros
votos por rodolfo hernán y que rolfo
raras también se anime y participe en
los debates que finalmente también la
gente pueda conocer sus verdaderas
propuestas y que enfrente la
responsabilidad de ser pues un líder de
una nación dani no claro que sí es muy
importante que participe en los debates
porque de ahí es donde inclusive
nosotros mismos sacamos nuestros
análisis y por eso es que está gratis y
la analizar las propuestas